Of a.
Just give me one SEC. I I'm needed.
Yeah.
OK, sorry about that. Yeah. So I guess,
yeah, let's kick it off, Andreas,
you're gonna share your screen and we've
prepared a confluence page and what we're
gonna do,
we're gonna walk through the items that
we've prepared.
And I think about 8 items or so in that
list.
So we'll just take a quick look and then
we'll run.
Based on that, Yep.
Sure.
Yep.
Can you guys see your screen?
Yep.
So since we have like only half an hour,
I guess we just start now.
Let me know if you have any questions,
Olli,
but I just otherwise I'll just go through
this list pretty quickly.
So the first one on the list is the
current Intune environment.
So basically as a bit of history,
we originally.
Have the hybrid join set up where we have
the yeah the the user device is still
hybrid joined previously,
but now since we upgraded to Windows 10
and now Windows 11 we have been on on the
AAD join.
Enter ID joint.
Basically set up and then some user.
Sorry users actually have the licence
assigned to them as E3 licence for us few
admin user actually have the Intune stand
alone licence licence to to to manage the
Intune itself.
The Arabic setup we have admin and also
help desk role define the help desk role
is for the IT support team where they
they they can perform limited function
that that can help with their role.
Basically any question on that or we can
we can move along.
No, no that.
Yeah, OK, cool.
But the device management bit,
we have multiple devices that we managed
to Intune.
So first one is windows and then the
windows itself we purchased from the
Microsoft partner where we have the
serial number registered in the autopilot
for our autopilot.
Enrollment. Yeah, there are multiple ESP.
You probably have seen that and I think
we already discussed it in the past as
well.
We have sort of the machine actually
enrolled and refreshed through the USB
stick method.
So they put through the USB stick stick
and then that USB stick will.
Also ask for the main that sorry,
not the main the prefix that they will
use whether they are actually a Melbourne
based device or Sydney based or other
than the two states, which is regional.
That's what we call and from that the
naming convention will be formatted
basically and deployed.
And then the rest of the applications is
deployed through the Intune plus kasaya
and then also of course in the future
will be data the Mac OS itself.
We have two devices at the moment.
One is for marketing,
the other one is for one.
Of our developer.
The the iOS and iPad OS we manage this
through. Sorry,
the devices are actually registered to
ABM where we enrolled.
If the the enrollment programme tokens we
need to renew that every every year as
annual annual basis basically.
VPP is where we we deployed our app that
we purchased through that that yeah VPP
programme basically the Android there is
no set corporate setup that we deployed
so far.
The AOSB however,
is configured and we have this aosb
mainly for for our teams phone that we
have in in the mid.
Rooms and also phone booth,
the device administrator as you are aware
is is already retired and so that
approach has been disabled.
So at the present time there are good mix
of aosb and device administrator managed
devices. So the device administrator.
Here is the one that's in the legacy
approach,
but moving forward that's no longer. Yeah,
it's not committed anymore.
We have not gone through converting those
devices. Unfortunately,
we did the tests and migration of level
to.
The IT users only back in the past,
but we stopped that the compliance policy
we have that configured per device type,
configuration profiles and baseline.
We do have that configured.
I believe you are the syndrome as well.
The first category scope dynamic groups,
yeah, OK,
so category we do have few categories
that we.
Use in the past.
I'm I'm not quite sure whether we're
Yeah.
still using that or not.
Nowadays with we do have like zoom and
corporate devices that that the well.
That we can we can we can set up
basically.
Yeah, there are.
There are few more categories and I guess
the list is not exhaustive,
but I guess at the point of preparing
this we that's the thing that came under
my mind.
The compliance policies and the
configuration profiles,
I think we've kept it really high level.
We have not gone down to list every item,
but I think.
Please take a look and see if we need
unpacking. We'll do that kind of thing.
Yeah, Andreas.
Hmm.
Yes, scope.
We are not using scopes at the States
only,
so that's not applicable to us the and
what. Sorry,
what's the context on this relay on
Dynamic group enter IDs?
Yeah.
So I guess we do in terms of classifying
the devices,
we do use dynamic and based on variables
We do, yeah.
we, yeah, we do,
we do use that fabric where possible,
Hmm.
yeah.
Yeah, OK. That's correct.
I think we already mentioned that in the
our previous meeting.
So we do have for instance the all
Devices Static group is the static group,
but in the members of that particular
group especially Dynamic Group with
relies on the sorry yeah dynamic group
based on the rule that.
Reset up Autopilot,
set up with clothing profile. All right,
device registration, user assignment.
This is part of the autopilot setup,
so when when they have the.
The serial number assigned to particular
user.
They they configured that in the
autopilot setup.
The white clothing itself,
we don't really have like a full white
clothing white clothing process because
the IT support team usually login on
behalf of user just to complete all the
setup.
End to end the first clean up routines
and last second management as per setting.
Yeah we don't really.
I think we leave it to the default
process at the moment.
We yeah, we do have some clean up.
I think it's like 90 days or something or
rather,
but over time what we have noticed that
Mm-hmm.
90 days enforcement is not great and I
see at times we need to manually perform
some level of clean up. But by default,
yes we do have that in place.
Hmm.
Yeah.
OK.
Any questions right up to here, Olli?
No, no.
Should be all right. All good.
I I have some. Yeah. Yeah,
Pretty stock standard, yeah.
No good.
it's it's it's the setup itself.
I I might have some questions.
Yeah.
Not really for the setup itself,
but just kind of like a background. Why?
OK.
Yeah, OK, easy, easy.
Why why you do something. Oh.
OK. Yeah. So,
so I think only with the background side
Sure.
Main mainly one couple not with you.
of things,
we were previously assisted by another
organisation.
I think you know who that is based on the
stuff that you see in Intune based in
Sydney.
And I guess when we were refreshing our
computers to the new surface or the
surface that we have right now,
we engaged them and and obviously part of
the engagement was to convert our hybrid
setup to enter ID. So yeah,
you you will see a mixed bag of ideas for
methodology and and whatnot. Yeah,
let's challenge those and and.
If I've got a question please.
I know this is half an hour,
but this is not the end of this piece of
work. You can definitely.
Yeah, yeah, no, this is just a. Yeah,
I think what I had a quick look like also,
like some cleanup definitely would be
good because there is a lot of apps and
Easy.
configuration policies that doesn't have
any any.
So in that, sorry in that case,
do we need to go through this list or we
Assignment, yeah.
Assignments or targets or anything.
actually want to just listen to your
question and we go from there only?
No, no, that's all.
I think that's that's good.
That's OK.
Yeah.
Like my my like application management of
those that's.
Yeah.
Really self exploring. Kind of. Yeah.
So probably my main thing would be the
Explain the three.
OK.
security stuff and updates.
It's one big thing like because there was
some item on the onboarding list for the
mobile device.
Patch management.
And So what do you do there and is there
any like,
do we need to change anything or are you
Hmm.
happy to just keep going,
but probably at the security and the
patching is the?
Main things probably.
Management, yeah.
And then there is probably some questions
of what's whose responsibility 'cause we
don't have access to that ABM,
for example. And so forth. Yep.
Alright,
let's carry on with the maybe we'll skip
the application management.
I think you're right.
It is stock standard and I.
Sorry Prakash,
can you go ahead with with number four,
please?
I I guess I pick you through at the
moment. I'll continue after.
That's OK. Yeah, that's OK.
So what I'll do? I'll.
I'll share my screen.
Let me know if you can see them. Yeah.
Yep, Yep.
Cool. Cool.
So coming back to item number three here.
I think we've got a fair share of
different types.
We've got Windows Store,
we've got lob store,
app build and so on and we've got
application assignment.
So So what we do when we need to set up
an application specific,
we have a convention where we would set
up a ADAG being application group.
Key Pass Key Pass notepad++ or or or the
name of the application so that we we add
the user into those application security
groups and then we'll that the device
targeting will happen.
If we need to do testing we'll we'll use
Yeah.
this particular convention where this
would be the host name.
And we'll do what we need to do and I
think based on the Datto,
you know that we've got couple of groups
that we commonly use in terms of in terms
of assignment. So that's that, right,
moving on to security and access
management,
we have got a couple of conditional
access policies in use.
But I think this was around evaluating
and trying to put Mam in place which
which obviously obviously had or ran into
a bit of a problem.
So we kind of put that on hold and then
if you look at compliance,
you'll notice that a couple of basic
policies, we do have Microsoft's best,
best practises.
Plan one and plan two.
I think it's compliance phase one,
phase two.
That is something that we are planning to
put forth,
but obviously we need a buy in from the
business.
I think in principle business is OK to do
it,
but we haven't really worked out that
particular bit. BitLocker,
yeah if we need to find out the BitLocker
key, we can just go to the same.
Local administrator rights? Yeah,
we don't use labs today.
We rely on entry IDs,
local administrator role to go in and
make changes or what have you user
firewall. So we rely on defender here.
Let me just click. I don't know.
I can't click no.
Mm-hmm.
This would be Ms defender.
Yeah.
So basically we have a base set firewall
and then depending on the role of the
user,
it will cumulatively apply the policy
basically.
So any any normal users who would fall
under this bucket,
ICT team would use this one and the
development will use this one based on
this particular base set policy.
So that's user firewall and on top of
that we have security baselines that we
have configured and that is as per Sox
review and advice.
You will find that I think we've got one
or two that we update over time. Yeah.
And I guess when it comes to antivirus,
we don't use defender Ms Defender at this
point in time we rely.
On vision one, apex one,
I think apex one is the older name and
it's now rebranded as Vision one under
the vision on product.
You've got apex one. What am I saying? OK,
so we've got that being the antivirus
protection or endpoint tool that we have
today.
Windows hello not in place just yet,
and obviously this is just a reiteration
that Ms Defender is not enabled at this
point in time.
Any question based on what you see for
security and access management?
No, no, that that's alright.
All right, cool.
Probably just an additional thing on on
BitLocker only.
We do have the BitLocker pin enabled as
well for user to enter the PIN and then
from time to time.
Not from time,
but it has happened that whenever the
firmware been upgraded,
if TPM somehow got erase or refresh,
it will prompt the user to re enter the
pin again.
So we have a script that runs in the
background that will check whether.
The TPM pin has been configured or not,
so if that status bit is says that it has
not been configured,
it will prompt with a window for the user
to actually enter their pin.
Other than that, once once it's entered,
it will not prompt the user again until
usually when that when that happens is is
if if the firmware and the hardware
firmware somehow get get refresh or or or
or updated.
Yeah. OK, cool. Yeah,
that that's a that's a good point.
And it's yeah.
You do have BitLocker pin.
That's a good one. Olli.
Anything else with the security access
management before we move on to the next
item.
Mm-hmm.
None.
No, I might. Well,
I I was going to ask the BitLocker pin.
Do you do you use the USB to configure
that or is that part of Intune
Mm-hmm.
configuration?
It's it's, it's part of the.
Or is it?
Is is that that is that the data script
that or Cassia script previously but or
is it?
There's an engine script that actually
deploys that and check as part of the app
deployment. Yeah,
it's not part of the configuration,
In TuneIn tune. Yep. Yep, Yep.
but it's part of the app deployment.
App deployment it just saying not not
configuration. Just give me one SEC. Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's a deployment, yeah.
OK, cool.
Uh.
Sorry, what am I doing? Protection.
Configuration. Windows. Yeah.
Go go to Windows, go to windows.
BitLocker. Yeah. Bingo. That's it.
So this is the one that does the reset
set the first one. Yeah.
So that's that script that does prompt
The top the first one.
and see if BitLocker when you boot up
that pin or it's not defined,
it'll have that.
So it does a couple of cheques that gets
evaluated every so often. You're right.
If let's say something is not right,
it will prompt the user.
OK, cool.
Is it just a PowerShell script?
It is a partial script, yes.
Yeah. Yeah, it does.
It's a PowerShell script that we probably
need to check and see if if we've got
access,
but I guess that is packaged into a
Intune win type solution and then gets
ruled out kind of thing.
There you go. All right, cool. Moving on.
We've got patch management,
patch management. We rely on casaya now.
Datto. And this one here. The update ring.
We used to be on Intune to roll out
feature updates and on an OS version.
Or even OS upgrades.
But these are all not in use today
because we find that some gap with Intune
the way Intune does it and we've moved to
to kasaiya even the the last Windows 10
to 11 upgrade was pretty much handled end
to end with.
Yeah.
With Kasaya,
but believe there was some issue with
Kasaya where we had to go back to Intune.
But having said all that,
we are now all on Windows 11,
so I think we don't really use these at
this point in time when it comes to iOS,
we do have two update policies.
Let me just I ***.
So this this part here.
I know this is deprecated but the
succession to that is not something
available to us just yet.
And when that is available we it will be
then put forth or I guess will be put in
place.
So this one here depending on the
scenario whether it's a critical issue
like a zero day 100.
Ability we'll do update in the next check
in. If it's not,
we'll just use the first one,
but half the time we end up updating both
because all the time we've got security
issues to to address and we do that.
So in in terms of updating it to the
latest version IT support.
IT support will sense check the the
updates,
so basically it'll just run update,
upgrade and just make sure that
everything is working as expected.
There's no show stoppers of any kind and
then they will advise.
Then advise the team to update. Yeah.
So I think that's what happens today.
Yeah. So. And at the same bucket,
we have got iPads as well and iPad
follows the same regimen in the sense
they will do a better check and then we
will update it accordingly to the next
available version.
And I think for this one here,
we have not gone with the clear.
Not with the version 2625. Sorry, no,
I think it's 26,
but we're still with the version 18.
But if the user so choose one to upgrade
to the latest version 26,
they can go ahead and do it.
But as far as we are concerned we we are
just pushing to 18,
but I think there is a call behind the
scene.
To actually push this to the latest clear
operating, is it called clear?
I'm not sure what the glass glass
operating are. You know what? Yeah.
So that's the version 26.
And this is that for iOS?
Any question with this piece of work?
None.
Batch management.
No, no, no, that's alright.
Cool. Yeah.
And I guess moving on to the next item,
we've got policy naming convention and
and typically what we do is we we try to
maintain GS 1 AU and then the item,
this is what we do default.
But of time often more than not we have
different approach where we've got.
Vendor like oral.
Then you've got the product name item
here is product my product name.
Yeah, so long. The item,
the labelling is clear.
I think that's fine.
So that's what we are looking to strike
and I guess the next item here is the
RBAC and I think the RBAC is pretty
standard in the sense that we've got one.
Helpdesk role and that helpdesk can do a
thing or two,
and the definition of that would be
pretty much under what you see on screen
on the right, yeah, so that's that.
But I think moving forward,
I understand that in oral we'll be
managing this and I guess in consultation
with GS1, so I think.
This is what we have today kind of thing.
Cool.
Yep.
Next item is maintenance and I think this
is where we have got couple of moving
parts that we need to you know make sure
that it's updated and and upgraded if we
have to in terms of ensuring Intune is
working as expected.
Now there are two parts to this.
One is within one. Yeah,
I guess I'm looking it down by operating
system. So you've got iOS,
you've got enrollment token.
This is something that expires every year
and so does the VPP side of things.
So VPPS,
we are pretty much under connector token
and you've got under here.
Yep.
Yeah, that's all good.
So we just need to make sure that these
two are safe, Karen.
And GS1 has got a contract that we we set
up to monitor the due dates,
but I guess we'll both of us will monitor
and eventually oral will carry on
monitoring this and we'll sunset our
tooling to monitor this.
I've not listed anything down in Android.
Why? Because there's nothing to to manage.
Maintain in this space simply because we
don't have corporate Android setup just
yet,
but I think we are looking to support
that in due time. Yeah.
So I think well we have whole heap of
BYOD users, but we BYOD users,
there's nothing much we can do to manage
or maintain because the device are not
ours to begin with.
So yeah,
I guess we don't have any any device
configuration that we roll out to BYODS,
but for corporate,
we are looking to have an enterprise set
up for Android users and and a bit of mix
MDM AM AM approach.
But at this stage in terms of maintenance,
there's nothing much in that space.
Now these two,
I think collectively we were thinking
about it and this is outside in tune,
but I think it would require update to
the corresponding device configuration.
So like this one here you've got, sorry.
So when we update SCAP or something,
or rather we need to update the the
certificates accordingly,
because we do use SCAP fair bit for
authenticating and relying on trusting
the computer and and we do use that when
that's up.
Yeah,
we'll just have to manage how we get
these items refreshed.
Same thing with Clear Pass and this,
these are the two that we thought he
would put this in here,
but not directly related to Intune itself.
Any questions before we just briefly talk
about the last item.
No, no. I have a couple,
but I I cannot ask them at the end at the
Easy.
end.
OK,
now next item is we've got Intune Phase
Oh.
two work.
I think this is where we were looking to
do this piece of work with oral and I
think oral,
let's just say that some decision made
behind the scene and we'll be doing some
activity in that space because we will be
procuring.
Doing some devices and we are looking to
reject some of the items that we have in
Intune just to make sure that it is in
tandem or in alignment with the current
best practises.
So this one here we may be making some of
those changes,
but we will work out and see what needs
doing or how we do it.
Because we don't want to be overlapping
the activities that we do in this space.
So it's a bit too early to be talking
about this,
but it's just a bit of a bit to be
transparent.
We are looking to make some changes to
support and there's a like we've got some
activities that we need to do and
remediate.
So yeah,
so I guess when that time comes and
hopefully by then Oro would look and
manage Intune end to end.
We'll have further conversation and as to
what that changes might entail and so on.
That is the last item that I've got.
Umm.
I guess now we'll open up for questions
and then what have you?
No, I don't have too many.
Couple that just now,
like we'll probably have more when we go
and look the environment and stuff.
But probably first one without looking
That that's fine, yeah.
corporate,
the personal devices you said you have
BYOD's already, but like what's your?
Just general policies for.
Do you do you allow BYODS on all
platforms? Do you book something?
The BYOD on all platforms we've got iOS
and BYOD.
Yeah. Yeah. Like what? What's your policy?
It's like, yeah, yeah. Like, like,
do you do you allow users to do it and do
you, like, use it,
that you you use Apple Business
management, Mac OS like iOS stuff.
Do you have also BYOD iOS policies
applied or?
You don't have anything applied to the
BYOD devices.
Yeah,
the I guess the BYOD is a tricky one
simply because we don't own the device.
So we don't really roll out any
configuration policy.
But what instead what we do is we we we
roll out conditional sorry compliance
policies just to make sure that the the
device is not jailbroken.
At least you've got coupler.
You know, like 4 characters of password.
I'm just just overly simplifying here.
So we've got a couple of compliance,
but not configuration for BYOD,
but BY by for corporate.
We do have whole heap of policies
starting from wireless to SCAP to.
Because Skype also is being applied for
iOS and also windows.
Yeah.
So we've got a whole heap of, you know,
that type of setup.
But with BYOD you like.
You don't restrict,
you don't restrict users to access
We we don't, we don't, we don't.
company data with anything or anything
like that.
Yeah,
that that is the ideal state that we need
to be in,
but we're just not there considering few
other activities that's happening. No,
we we are not.
So accessing corporate data is definitely
allowed on BYOD.
I'm not sure how auto does it do do you
need to be on a on a compliant corporate
device before you can access your data.
Or you are able to access on your BYOD
computers.
I don't actually, to be honest,
because I don't manage,
Tried it.
manage our internal stuff.
I don't know how it's managed.
OK, OK. Yeah.
I I think it's a mem.
I I think we use MEM most of most of it.
OK, OK.
Gotcha.
So you have your work profile that host
your applications.
Yeah, easy.
At least on androids or iOS I don't,
I don't know, but I would say say ma'am.
Yeah,
I I think we had a conversation with your
architect.
I cannot recall what's his name.
I don't know whether Ian,
you remember his name and he was.
He was saying that oral is or is pretty
much using MEM for their mobile fleet.
Which was definitely a fresh breath of
fresh air, I suppose. But yeah,
'cause we we have been looking at it for
MDM and a bit of old school,
I suppose looking at MDM but not looking
through MEM.
But to be fair mem is rather recent of,
you know offering.
Sorry George, I need to jump off.
Maybe Olli is it worth it if we ask
George to set up another call and then we
can go through your observation and you
run through the document page that you
have on the on the left hand side.
If you need us to unpack something,
let us know and then we'll unpack that
further.
Yeah. Yeah. But I think it was pretty,
pretty comprehensive and that gives a
cool background, at least starting point.
Yeah.
And yeah, like I said,
when we and when we start managing it and
or we manage it already a little bit,
but like I think yeah we will come up
Yeah.
with questions then like why why it's
something done some some way but for what
Easy, yeah.
I had a quick look it it looks pretty.
Yeah.
Straightforward.
I think the updates were the biggest
thing because I couldn't see anything in
there,
but I actually didn't course it checked
that particular sports because it's
should be depreciated. But yeah,
that's all right. Yeah, yeah.
This one here. Yeah, yeah. OK, cool.
Thank you for your very much for your
time. I guess I'll talk to you later.
No worries.
Yeah, yeah. Just only for yeah. Prakash,
we need to go. Yeah. Yeah.
OK, I need to drop off. I need to. Yeah.
Sorry. I need to go. OK. Catch you later.
Yep. Thank you. Bye.
Bye.
So you have the access to that particular
page, so just feel free to, you know,
Yeah, yeah, I I I checked.
go through it again,
go through the notes after the transcribe
if you have any more questions or you
know if you want to put us some comments
in the in that page and then you know let
us know and we can come back and.
Yeah. Bring bring those in for you.
Yeah. No,
I think main thing was those corporate
personals.
Just just what your general.
Oh.
Approach to them are do you support
personal devices?
Yeah.
I see your personal call windows or
personal.
Mm-hmm.
Support them.
None.
As in like if they let's say I don't know
can't access outlook.
Yeah,
they I think we generally do not have any
Or emails.
restriction at the moment, but yeah,
they if they access it they they access
it. But yeah, we're looking, you know,
in the coming features to lock it out.
But yeah, as as it stands, yeah,
we we don't say like officially
supporting it,
but yet the access is there.
Yep, Yep.
So they can access if they want to or
Yeah, it's alright. Yeah.
need to. Cool. Yeah, that's that's fine.
I will have a quick look and we will have
a look at the configurations. And yeah,
I think like I said,
that document is good,
really good starting point.
It gives us a background of.
That's good.
Of what you're doing at the moment,
and yeah, that's good.
Yeah.
Good. All right. Thank you very much.
We'll chat again. Thanks Andreas. Bye bye.
Wait, can I ask one question?
If you have time just out of curiosity?
Sir.
Yeah.
Like why what you're using the USB stick
for when you deploy a PC?
Like when when you do a,
when you do a new machine like. Why?
It's it's a bit of legacy.
Why do you do ausb deployment rather than
a Intune or something else?
Yeah, because because.
Yeah, OK,
that's that's a bit bit of history only.
Yeah.
So back in the days when we first onboard
the journey of of having the AAD device
joined,
when we refreshed our our device with
Windows 10.
So we engage with the external party and
then back then the Intune renaming.
It's not working as expected because
Intune is just early release,
so they have a lot of issue with renaming,
so that's why he created that solution.
The USB stick with the prefix and things
like that. I know that.
Has the policy to to to enrol and rename
the the device, but that's.
That's basically the approach that we
have taken so far and then the USB stick
itself has the Windows PE.
Built in which will deploy the OS to the
device,
so his argument is it will be quicker
instead of the device connected to
Internet and download the OS installation.
So that's that's.
Basically, but he started behind it.
Yep, Yep.
So mainly like device name is the what's
the biggest reason?
Kind of making it a little bit quicker.
Quicker. Yeah, for deployment.
Yep, OK, cool. Cool.
I just wanna just wondering. What?
Yeah.
Why what? Yeah, what's the history on it?
Are you are you thinking like it can be
fully online without USB stake? Is it?
Is that what you're thinking?
Oh, it sounds like that possibly.
Oh, good. Oh, good. Yeah. Look,
certainly there.
There will be things we can, you know,
always improve on just like anything else.
Yeah. If you go through it,
if there's any improvement opportunity,
feel free to let us know we can.
And if there's a, you know,
a reason not to do it, yeah,
we'll take it on board.
Yep, Yep, definitely cool. No worries.
I think that's it.
Yeah.
None.
I will have a look at the go through the
Intune with the documentation now,
and yeah,
we'll come back if we have anything.
Yeah. Nice.
And I'm sure we have something at least.
Sure.
Alright, thank you. Bye.